[Music]
hi i'm jasmine and today we're going to
be making an epic cheesy volcano fried
rice it's absolutely delicious packed
with flavor it's savory it's spicy
slightly sweet and there's bacon garlic
and cheese so we can't go wrong with
this dish i've already prepped all the
ingredients so let's start cooking
we're going to start by making the fried
rice i'm adding some chopped bacon to my
pan over medium heat and we're gonna
cook it until it's about halfway done
we're gonna let the bacon fat render oh
it smells so good already we can add in
our garlic and our green
onions gotta get every last bit we're
just gonna let that cook for a couple of
minutes so the garlic and the green
onions can soak in the flavor of the
bacon it smells so good i just can't
focus
i can't i can't focus
when i can't
i can't talk
and smell this at the same time once it
looks something like this we can go
ahead and make some space in the middle
and throw in our chopped kimchi
now you can drain your kimchi if you'd
like but because i'm aggressively in
love with the intense flavor of
condensed kimchi juice i will not be
draining it so we're going to cook down
the kimchi until it dries up a little
bit and turns from this vibrant dark red
to a little bit of a reddish brown we
want to make sure that it's well reduced
otherwise once we add in the rice and
the sauce it's just going to be one
soggy wet mess also if you're not a huge
kimchi fan you can reduce the amount of
kimchi in here or even just take it out
completely but if you haven't tried
cooked kimchi i really do recommend that
you try it because it tastes so
different from raw kimchi
free facials
so once your kimchi looks something like
this we're ready to add the sauce and to
make the sauce we're just going to add
in two tablespoons of gochujang which is
korean red pepper paste two tablespoons
of mirin which is sweet rice wine one
tablespoon of soy sauce and one
tablespoon of sesame oil and just give
it a good mix just gonna pour it all
over the kimchi bacon garlic and green
onions i mixed all the sauces first in a
different bowl i think it helps break
down the pepper paste better and mixes
in better but you can add it directly to
the pan if you want perfect let's mix
this up
until it's well combined
wow
the smells are immaculate in my
apartment
yum okay this is coming together so
nicely i'm gonna add in two cups of
leftover rice leftover okay guys
left over rice you can use fresh if you
want to but then don't get mad at me if
your fried rice is wet and soggy use
leftover rice gonna break up the larger
chunks and just get all of this
well incorporated we're gonna cook the
rice for three to four more minutes and
i'm actually gonna let the rice crisp up
on the bottom when my best friends and i
made fried rice in college we would
always let the rice crisp up and then we
would fight for that scorched rice
because the texture is just so
so good it's actually a very popular
snack amongst koreans it's called
nurunji and it's literally just scorched
rice it's
so good
all right y'all this looks about done so
we're gonna turn off the heat and we're
going to transfer this into my volcano
shaped bowl and while i'm a thousand
percent positive that every single one
of you has a volcano shaped bowl in the
off chance that you don't have a volcano
shaped bowl you can just use a small to
medium sized bowl as deep as you can
find this is the bowl i'm using i
usually use this for my noodles and it's
actually the perfect volcano shape let's
carefully transfer all of our fried rice
into the bowl and we're going to press
it down until it's compact
now we're going to safely flip this onto
our new pan your heat should not be on
yet don't burn yourself i'm actually
going to put the pan on top of the fried
rice
and we're going to flip it
okay
give it a little jiggle so it comes out
i'm going to indent the top a little
careful if you press too hard and too
fast it will break apart
i'm getting so excited
why is food so fun
and so good i'm gonna make a fat crevice
over here so we can get a lot of egg and
cheese lava our volcano looks ready for
the egg and cheese lava let's turn our
heat back on
to medium
and it's time for some action baby i
have four whisked eggs in here and i'm
just gonna pour it over our volcano
oh
my god
ah
it looks so good
cheesy goodness guys gonna top it with
mozzarella
and just pour it all over our eggs
if you love cheese you know i'm not
stopping you from adding more
if you want to go the extra mile
sometimes i like to add sweet corn
and it just
food heaven
we're gonna cover our pan just until the
eggs cook through and the cheese melts
avoid overcooking your eggs because we
don't want it to be dry and rubbery we
want it to be light and fluffy
all right guys looks about done this is
the cheesy volcano fried rice a
delicious kimchi fried rice surrounded
in an egg and cheese moat topped with
even more cheese this is a good day
[Music]
moment of silence please
sometimes food just needs
a moment to shine
wow that's so good of course it's not
too different from your average kimchi
fried rice but making it like this is so
fun
i'm gonna invite my boyfriend to try it
george you want to come try this
sure
whoa that is beautiful i kind of ruined
it well i mean it already looks so good
the lot was flowing out you want to try
yes i would love to
good
you did a good job that's so good all
right guys we're going to go ahead and
finish the rest of this if you end up
making the cheesy volcano fried rice
make sure to take a picture and tag me
on instagram and if you want to see more
of my content make sure to subscribe to
bring me bye
guys oh yes
[Music]
you